[Music]
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spiderman
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
me too don't
but there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe
you know to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
and everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop him
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
july 20th
1969.
it's one small
[Music]
step school you were taught that apollo
11 lost contact with the world for two
minutes
[Music]
not true
they found something on that day
that they kept him for 50 years
and now
it's too late to stop
in breaking news the governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation of the
entire west coast
moving to higher ground it's the only
possible chance of surviving
stay away my brothers and sisters
stay away
this planet
has suffered five extinctions
this
is going to be the sixth
oh he dead
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
[Music]
[Music]
it's expired sir oh come on man you know
how many times i've been in and out of
this gate with that excuse me what's the
odds on isis about the vehicle sir you
want me to step off the vehicle
he's with ranger battalion
ranger battalion
i've been busting my ass to get my mind
and my body back into a good place i
need to get back in the game sir you
want to get back in the game prove it
sergeant rodriguez was a legend family
funeral sunday outside of nogales they
won his dog at the funeral you do this
and you're back in the game
she won't work with anyone one minute
she's good the next minute she's sending
three guys to the er what's up dawg and
you're gonna go on a little road trip
easy what are you all so scared smell it
out big
what is your deal man maybe just take
crazy down one notch
[Music]
right no no no no
no you're just a demon you're just a
demon
whatever happened to you dogs you used
to be eleven
[Music]
you're so
good how'd you make her get out of your
hand i just talked to her see she's just
a noodle she just knew so good
[Music]
you don't do anything else psychotic on
this trip maybe we can have some fun is
that a deal
lulu is that you good girl you give hugs
now really lulu gets the best of you've
never had a lulu
no we don't we don't we don't exactly
hug
so you're telling me that nuke was just
as messed up as louis i had to work him
every day for six months when he stopped
struggling that's when i realized maybe
i could stop struggling too
it's okay it's just lightning right
look at that
she's never slept in a nice bed before
ain't no shame in wanting a big comfy
mattress i was hoping you might have a
room for me and my little girl is that a
purple heart was she wounded um
yes she she was thank you for your
service
we've never seen this dog exhibit any
aggressive behavior before never she
loves people
[Music]
oh my god i can i can see
you're definitely not the girl i thought
i'd be in the tub with but
i'll take what i can get at this point i
guess
it was a name that sounded so sweet so
seductive come meet the family everybody
this is patricia and this is my family
they had it all
worth style
power who wouldn't care for
[Music]
ah that it's you my nephew i have been a
gucci all my life
it is an empire
you can help the family which is not
exciting and everybody knows it at least
it's my name sweetie
our name
[Music]
which needs sweetie blood fuji
is what i say is this is not a woman's
game
remember that
madness who does he think he is it's
time to take out the trash
gucci is a rare animal
must be protected
protected from home
[Music]
is my name too
who does what
oh
[Music]
don't
miss
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't consider myself a particularly
ethical person no but i am fair
i subscribe to
unconventional punishments
[Music]
i will ask you simple questions you will
answer in short sentences only what you
believe to be absolute truth
absolute truth
i can do that
now
brief as you can
what is your name
stanton carlisle
are you a true medium yes i am
mr carla
doctor about that
please lie down
can you read minds yes i can under the
right circumstances
keep your answers brief
what do i want to be found out same as
everybody else
are you in contact with the beyond
well we've had our share of snake
charmers in the past
we deal with them
[Music]
you know people stand they fool
themselves
i've given you a fortune it's time that
you delivered
when does it end
i want to know
if you displease the right people the
world closes in on you very very fast
[Music]
i remember revelations
and i looked
as he opened the sixth
seal there was a great earthquake
judgment day
raise a call i'm calling about what
happened to new york
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
oh my god
what is happening here her grandfather
was a ghostbuster something was coming
and he knew it
i think we opened the gates of hell
hey
have you missed us
[Music]
all right let's do it again
marry me marry me
marry me marry me
the marry me concert is something you
will not want to miss
in 36 hours superstar kat valdez and
grammy winning bastian will perform
their new song marry me and exchange
files in front of a streaming audience
of 20 million people
i'll be the one in the veil charlie this
is once in a lifetime i've got my
daughter tonight good i've got three
tickets for tonight bring her dad you
haven't had any fun since mom left just
say yes
what am i doing here
okay let's go we only have five minutes
what's everybody looking at nothing give
me your phone
kat valdez's husband-to-be bastion
caught cheating with her assistant
we love you cat hold this i'm told that
uh 20 million people are supposed to
watch as we take our vows they say if
you want something different you have to
do something different
why not
yes
[Music]
i'll marry you
you
go go
do you
some guy
take cat to be a lawfully wedded wife
okay
that was crazy kat valdez left the guy
from the concert then also married her
uber driver it's an insane situation i
say we offer five thousand dollars and
let it all blow over or i could stay
married to him
i started something last night and if i
don't finish it i'll look crazy we gotta
get out in front of this hi
it's three months i don't even know her
we both did this so whether we like it
or not we're in this together we have to
embrace the spontaneity of the moment i
don't want to be the punchline
what do i do just stand and smile
this is the most unbelievable thing that
could ever happen in life
right now 237 000 people are like he
looks like he's a math club i am in a
math club
i don't know hanging with you guys today
i don't know it made me feel kind of
normal come with me to the fall semi
informally are you asking me to the
school dance well i could leave a note
in your locker
[Music]
call me if you're lonely
hello
[Music]
are you afraid she'll fall back and love
bastion and dump you
[Music]
i'd be afraid of that too we don't need
to pretend i don't fit
[Music]
this is smart
i think we left smart six weeks ago
i was on my way to you
who do you think you are a man some fan
no i'm not a fan just well i mean i am
now
[Music]
flight recorders are on t minus five
four
three
two
one
[Applause]
zero we have not
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
that all the children
to infinity
and
football
tell me about that as long as i have a
ball in my hand
i feel a lot
kind of like how i feel right now
i'm staying here i got work today work
the nfl is not going to draft some dude
from the one double a school in iowa
there were other offers i called every
team in the nfl no one's interested
[Music]
can i get one of your applications
i promised that i would take care of you
and the kids
so that is exactly what i'm gonna do
this is your dream to give
[Applause]
[Music]
kurt warner you got the whole package
kid
and the world just needs more time to
see it
he came up with this whole arena concept
arena football
it's like a circus
people love the circus i like the
surface
you pay me per touchdown i also pay you
to win that's gonna be fine
kurt we've been trying to reach you i'm
sorry who are you i'm with the rams
this guy's old slow is molasses he's
beneath the standard to this franchise
that's what people said about me when i
came here
all those years gave us something others
didn't have
media ready for this moment
out of the arena it's one of those
stories for the movie the perfect guy
here he was bagging grocery five years
ago
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my time i know who i am and i
know why i'm here
[Music]
did you bleed on the carrots well i died
yep probably
[Music]
happy christmas just did alive yes i
think so
jesus they're early
tony and simon robbed the petrol station
oh what fun
we make tremendous criminals that felt
so good
we're all getting old we were getting
old
[Music]
it's just one potato each just one for
everyone
should anyone watch the queen's speech
well she's clearly in some bunkers set
up you know filled with tins of baked
beans and dog food
[Music]
here's to the lives that we've shared
to our beautiful children
our beautiful friend
may we rest in peace
[Applause]
i just think we should be honest with
the kids we know the russians want us
all dead they're sending poisonous gas
to kill us all in the morning it's not
the russians it's the planet it's very
upset
it will kill anything and anyone that is
still alive
[Music]
[Applause]
we just want to make sure that you
understand that as your parents
we are not to blame
clearly it's not your fault either
[Music]
[Music]
way of living like that
it's time for us to move out and make
our mark on the world
oh no
those ding-dongs went back to the lost
world oh and i thought i made bad
choices
the lost world
the world's most dangerous place
wait a minute can you repeat that
i had a marshmallow in my ear oh [ __ ]
crying out loud
what brings you to here
we came here to live a life of adventure
like you
i'm starting to question our judgment
this is the perfect time to do it
it's time to get
[ __ ] violent [ __ ] you like a superhero
i wouldn't use the term superhero
i mean i wouldn't stop you from using it
ah
i love family reunions
i have climbed
the highest mountains
i have run
through the fields
only to be
with you
only to be with you
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
[Applause]
[Music]
dream big trees
we just gotta be brave now wrong again
again
you know i believe it's
you will never be great johnny
what i'm looking for
[Applause]
i
still haven't found
what i'm looking for
lee i wear what i want say what i want
24 7 365.
i know it's a lot
but i don't have time to mess around
oh about that hustle am i right
this is gonna be the best year ever
and nothing's gonna get in my way
breakfast is ready
[Music]
is everything okay
i'm a gross red monster
[Applause]
don't look at me stay back this happened
already
what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas are you kidding me this
little quirk right between our family
[Music]
you're so cute sick i've always wanted a
tail i'm a freak we love you mae you're
our girl
whoa you're you
[Music]
do you know how dangerous this is you'll
get whipped up into a frenzy and panda
all
but maybe i like this new me
mama's girls
it's gonna be me
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run do it now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of you
who wants to hunt
and consume blood
and you control it
i don't know
half the city wants to kill you
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
dr mike you and i should stay in touch
not doing anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
action lucy
i'm home
[Music]
why is this coming out now
lucille ball's a threat to the american
way of life does the fbi have any case
against lucy
i need you to help me save my marriage
how many times i gotta explain where i
was and what i was doing you gotta
explain are you being funny i'm lucille
ball when i'm being funny you'll know
this is getting out of hand have you
been cheating on me the story's made up
if they fool me if they push you
we're done
sorry
i got lost for a second
[Music]
[Music]
you're my hero
i care about what works
i care about what's funny
i care about you
oh you're scaring this [ __ ] i was just
gonna say
good show good show good show
[Music]
we've been through worse than this
we have
no
[Music]
this is mission control to jay
i can't believe it's been two years
since i saw you last
how's bobby
i missed you both so much
i'm heading out on another secret
mission
i want to come see you but
i need to keep fighting
everything i do
is to protect you
come here
keep your eyes open
the game is called get in the car as
fast as humanly possible you let him
beat
you it's okay
what's going on here road trip with my
boys at 3am
no please stop
this operation extends to all adjacent
states
they have no idea the kind of danger
that they're in
why can't we go home they're hitting a
road trip it's a rescue mission
nothing bad's gonna happen too while i'm
around besides if this ain't a hell of
an adventure i know what it is
i think i'm dude it up no because you're
so sure
if we do this thing right
you will always be a hero to your sons
you ever heard of the three musketeers
the toughest soldiers there ever was
they could survive anything because they
stuck together now you're telling me if
we don't stand by each other we can't
get through anything
yes
i know again
[Music]
so
[Music]
years ago
before you were born
i met a man
and now i've come into the possession of
a villa in the south of france what
three two one
[Music]
better be warned
the british are coming
[Music]
and with that i will say good night and
leave you to discuss my mysterious past
[Music]
many years ago
this candle blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita came to life with
[Music]
in
magic
every member of our family cecilia
was given their own magical gifts
uh-huh uh-huh i understand you
i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like
perfect
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in his family
you just healed my hand with an adepa
con queso
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
i'm losing my gift
[Music]
the fate of the family
is gonna come down to you
i can't do this let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
where you least expect it
[Music]
a lot of stairs
but at least i'll have a friend nope you
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
every kid has that one gift they want
more than anything for christmas
this is the story of mine
bookends and they have baseballs on them
i see that no not those nintendo
a maze of rubber wiring and electronic
intelligence so advanced it was deemed
not a video game but an 8-bit
entertainment system
no nintendo on my house i second that
looks like a no-go on nintendo
i needed a christmas miracle
the year was 1987 or was it 88 super
bowl wasn't it okay does it really
matter dad oh
okay the year was the late 80s i was 11
years old did you wear a helmet yeah we
always wore helmets in the 80s
me and my friends would do anything just
to play one any of you huddled masters
want to play
what have you brought me
untraceable cash money
[Music]
one thing became clear i needed to get
my own
this is bigger than christmas
[Music]
this is our vietnam i don't think that
means what you think it means i have no
idea what it means we're gonna get in so
much trouble sometimes during christmas
just when you think that all hope is
lost something magical happens
[Music]
sold out in 20 minutes that's ugly one
woman punched a grandma right in the
throat
same family too
are you making all this up no no no way
you guys here in the race selling
contests first prize is a brand new
nintendo entertainment system
i'm gonna kill you
hold on
[Music]
there are no rules
[Music]
that nintendo's mine
what do you want to buy a reef
ma this kid thinks your wreath sucks
video games
have been doing all kinds of strange
things to children
what it was the 80s stuff got real
red dog this is bluebird this is rainbow
one what happened to red dog i changed
it well let's change names now this is
millennium falcon super cool
love it rated pg
[Music]
i'm trapped here day after endless day
with my one maniacal
nemesis
four complaints this week four this is
the period when you take a period and
put it put that doughnut hole away or
i'm gonna shove it up
you two are the worst part of my job
we're gonna be hiring a managing
director will oversee each department
the job is mine shortcake if you get the
job i'll resign just like you will if i
do ah but i'm incapable of giving you
that pleasure well it's not the first
time you've said that to a woman is it
are you and he like there's eye there no
i hate him with a passion
wowzers what's the occasion
psychological warfare i wonder what it's
like to use raw animal magnetism as a
weapon i had some weird dreams last
night i was in bed naked
i have a theory
what are we doing this game that we play
every day hating someone feels
disturbingly like falling in love with
them
let's play a different game a starting
over game why i don't want to be some
experiment before you settle down
[Music]
we are competing for the same job it is
impossible to trust each other i'm in
this you can trust that
i told you she'd back off if you let her
think that you could pet the pony
i don't need any help beating her
you would just do whatever it takes to
win whatever this is i don't want to do
it anymore
i don't understand you i thought you
hated me yeah
so what game should we play now
[Music]
lucy when you first met josh what did
you think i thought he was cold and
freakishly uptight i thought lucy was a
spineless kiss-ass it was hate at first
sight
[Music]
where have you been oh you were supposed
to be here working i lost track of time
this is the real world sometimes you
just gotta let your dreams go
i just scribble in my notebook i'm a
stock boy that's it you are a legit
designer let me add them
dude i love it
oh
i want to lick them
i'm kira oh hold up
kira king aka sneaker royalty
boom the king's charity yeah design some
sick kicks show off your talent at the
most exclusive sneaker event of the year
that could happen this is your shot come
on get up
you've got sneakers to make
kicks
[Music]
it's you did you design this yeah you're
the guy
that everybody's been talking about
tonight this is destiny
my soul's got so i've been this ghost i
was three years old i'm going for my
goal so
is
[Music]
jane
you have no family
you have absolutely nothing to lose
that is the gift
and you must learn to use it
[Music]
when did you become a writer miss jane
fairchild
three times over
the day i was born
the day mr paxton gave me my typewriter
[Music]
and the third
[Music]
it's a secret
[Music]
good morning beechwood house jay
that you
11 o'clock
[Music]
not met like this before
[Music]
who was that jay wrong number sir
on a sunday
what happens
he's always late
be forever yet
stand there
he's studying is he
what are you doing
studying
[Music]
good for him
wish i could take you out champagne and
oysters
i've got to get married become a lawyer
[Music]
that's what's expected of yes
and you jane
what would you do
i want to write about life
[Music]
pain
and anguish
[Music]
you can summon the memory
can't you jane
for me
[Music]
for you
[Music]
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil
why are you back here clear your
conspiracies weren't true when we were
kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this
i'm afraid claire i'm afraid of what
they're going to do to this town
see umbrella they have an incident i'm
talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
people are getting sick
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
[Music]
we have to contain this
great
[Music]
i
should split
[Music]
deep breath and up get real high at
night
[Music]
we're gonna take umbrella down
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm looking for someone who can help me
gain an audience with the czar perhaps
you can be of assistance
i only make decisions when my stomach is
full or my balls are empty
well thank god dinner is being served
[Music]
things
can grow into big problems
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
while governments wait for orders
our people take action
welcome to the club
you're going to need a suit
[Music]
very clever
time to dance
[Music]
stop [ __ ] about
[Applause]
[ __ ] this gentleman's [ __ ] i'm gonna
love calling you
[Music]
we shall see
[Music]
what's this
it's a journal so you can write to your
son
what do i write tell them who you are
what you believe in
and tell them you love them
[Music]
dear jordan
the moment i met your mother i knew she
was the one he is not exactly my title
[Music]
and after some convincing she fell for
me too
i think you are beautiful
[Music]
i want to see more of your city i'll
take your state your zip code
[Music]
real love takes sacrifice
[Music]
we can make this
[Music]
work you came into our lives
and you were a blessing
how come you barely ever talk about them
i think about them all the time
always be courageous in everything you
do
but never be afraid to cry
[Music]
yes
will try i pray i don't run out of time
i love you to fix you
i was just thinking that if you need sex
just to help you get through it
then i don't want another woman i hope
you don't expect me to extend that same
offer because you better keep that
locked up
exclusively in movie theaters this
christmas
that was long ago
there's the next house you get in you
get the stuff i tell you to and you get
out i'll bring my garage this time
[Music]
let's do it
[Music]
lucky here nobody move
down
hey there buddy
now why are you running
there's only one person that could have
done this
it's the gardener
gardner he's military he's a killer and
so are all of you
[Music]
they've seen my face they all died
what are you gonna do
save your family
if you want something done properly
do it yourself
so uh gardening have you always enjoyed
it
yes
[Music]
what's up with the picture
that
is a 70-75 bmw csl
king of beauty say you're back 135k
i'm saving up
gonna get one how's that going for you
considering you just got fired had a
couple g saved hmm only another 133 000
to go
[Music]
i know a guy
nath clark him is curved in about 14
stick ups he's slick
he's the fourth man collection
never done a robbery before
[Music]
if you don't know why you're doing this
then you need to get out the car robbing
a bank
you know that's mad right honey yeah
because it's a police fact
what is he talking about i'm doing this
job it's suicide just think about it man
use your head
no more
guns load of the blanks doesn't matter
people see guns they automatically think
death the getaway car ain't always
messing around mess around
getting lit up
right free advice
he's playing in the bank goes wrong
you're probably gonna have to kill
somebody to get out
security guard
woman
maybe even a kid
are you 12 i'm 16. don't
[Music]
did you come here to be a murderer i
thought you came here to rob a bank you
got to be in this do you really want to
kill a little girl
is that why you came here today
man all i really want is to buy a 70 to
75 bmw csl 3.0 and drive away from here
forever well god damn
[Music]
ronald whitlock i'm not sure if you
heard but there's been an incident
my son
cops killed him it's a bit more
complicated than that it's crystal clear
to me
i did not think i'd see your ass in work
today we come from tougher part than
that why don't you like ex-military or
something yeah
you're a fugitive i killed two cops
i got a bone to pick
for my son
[Music]
[Applause]
if things don't go to my satisfaction
i'll flood this whole place
we're all gonna drown
[Music]
sorry dude you got a town to save
there's a rogue hostage
with some sort of military background
find them
[Music]
i gotta figure out a way to stop this
fool
they got guns
you got a goddamn ghost
i got bear guns
that is beautiful
this is my legacy
you're crazy man you should try a little
bit of
crazy
you've been gifted this beautiful house
well you live here
can you believe it
[Music]
they've wanted to keep the place in your
family jamie
we really appreciate the house
well then you know
it's got a hole in the roof the wheels
they'll do a good job jamie
you just carry on with your day as if we
weren't here
there is one thing i need to show you
and it's a little bit peculiar
every evening before sunset she'd leave
a blood offering here sorry did you say
blood
for who
for the red caps
[Music]
now i need feeding
you'll be hungry
can i get in my own house please you
want a deer how many times have the
english come to this country and told us
what areas
what did you leave out tonight oh shoot
you can't miss a single day
hello
is anyone there
i can't be scared i'm not in my own
house
don't leave your wrists alone with the
lads
[Music]
we just came here for some peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you want to come over and have a drink
[Applause]
[Music]
we got the house rules on the board over
here it's best two out of three to keep
the action moving okay
stay safe out there looks like you're
fixing a run no you
that's a blockbuster card
i don't like getting hustled
and things that i don't like wind up in
a hole in the [ __ ] desert
you know i've been trying to track her
down for over a year she's important to
me man
see you're still playing music yeah yeah
still banging away you know it's been
really good to me okay that's amazing
you got taking care of
[Music]
are so here
it's always just a matter you put
together
once again you have no idea what you are
talking about
[Music]
[Music]
let nobody out
it's gonna be great it'll be just like
old times that's scary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]